alright I'm business okay thanks for
sticking around guys I know it's the end
of the day and I have a train to catch
anyway so I can take this real quick but
I'm here today to talk about GPUs my
name is Kelly O'Brien
I'm a developer advocate for map D very
recently but before that I spent some
time calling myself a data science
product engineer and like Jared said I
also do a lot of things for our ladies
specifically our ladies TC and some
cloud stuff for our ladies Global which
is pretty cool I publish about play
series called our profile on the open
side blog which I like a lot so check
that out if you haven't seen it and I
just want to hop right into it so I'm
here today to convince you to be
interested in GPUs if you aren't already
or you've heard about GPUs and GPU
computing and you don't know what it is
yet so let's start I want to talk to you
about what GPUs are and wouldn't we
introduce GPUs to people oftentimes
you'll do it or you'll see it done in
conjunction with talking about what CPUs
are so GPU is as you may have guessed an
acronym and it stands for graphics
processing unit GPU processors were
designed for the purpose of rendering
images animations videos to your
computer screen but in the last decade
we've been seeing them applied to a lot
more applications it's common to see
them alongside CPUs as I said and so
I've drawn up the classic like CPU GPU
core comparison so a core is just a unit
office unit that receives instructions
and and does the processing of
calculations and performance things
based on those instructions so CPUs are
often called the the brain of the
computer they have multiple cores maybe
like a couple but those cores are really
fancy and they're awesome and they do
awesome stuff and they're optimized for
doing serial tasks
gpus on the other hand may have hundreds
or thousands of these cores and but
don't get too excited because they don't
do all of the awesome stuff that CPU
cores do they do very basic tasks but
there's a lot of them and they're
optimized for doing parallel tasks here
to explain the difference between serial
and parallel parallel task execution are
the Mythbusters
if you haven't seen this video it's
really great I just created two gifts of
it on the one side you see CPUs where
they have this robot that aims and fires
paintballs aims and fires to create
eventually this rendering of a smiley
face on a big canvas and on the other
side they've created this monstrosity of
a machine that has thousands of pipes
with a single paint ball in each pipe
and they hit a button and all at once
all those people shoot at the canvas and
create a rendering of the Mona Lisa so I
don't know if that's the perfect
explanation of the difference between
GPU and CPU but it is very fun and if
you watch the video online you can hear
Adam Savage just maniacally laughing
after he hits the button which is really
great but was talking about why people
are so excited about GPUs you know like
when I first heard about GPUs it was
from my dad actually and I think I was
in college he's an aerospace engineer
and he does start camera stuff and some
of this stuff I don't her stand and he
asked me hey do you know CUDA and I was
like dad why would I do coot it with
what is that but hearing about it again
in graduate school and then again over
and over now recently JJ gave a really
awesome keynote at this past our studio
conf and in it he talked about how GPU
computing just revolutionized the field
of computer vision through deep learning
if you haven't seen that that's also
available online I highly recommend it
it's long but it's worth it so people
are doing really cool stuff with GPUs
and here are some other things that
they've done so
I want to talk about what problems GPUs
are good for it outlet what applications
have people found for that but first off
they started being a graphics card then
people discovered you could do high
performance computing with them from
there we discovered applications in
machine learning revolutionize deep
learning from there even further
general-purpose computing for big data
analytics and finally database
operations so today I want to talk about
this last you kind of pieces further on
but first just kind of to sell you on
this like I know that a lot of people
get up here people from the data science
industry and they say you know we're all
dealing with big data and like I want to
be real I know a lot of people a lot of
people in this room probably aren't
day-to-day dealing with big data but
this was one of the quotes that came out
of my are profile project my interview
project with our open sigh the interview
was actually conducted by Sean cross but
it was with dr. Julius Stuart Landis and
I love this quote from Parrish says I
learned a code and a total panic because
my data was too big to be opened in
Excel so because I was trying to figure
out science and coding at the same time
I conflated research with data science
I was confusing my thesis questions that
no one had ever asked before with data
questions that many people had asked
before and salt so if anything comes
from you attending my talk today I hope
that like even if you aren't ready for
Big Data data analytics like maybe
someday you will be and you'll remember
the stuff that I've talked about today
and you won't be lost in this total
panic where you don't know what to do
and you think these problems have never
been solved before so with that how much
does it cost
I love Wired magazine I read it all the
time this title in it from an article in
2013 really got me though
it was now you can build Google's
$1,000,000 artificial brain on the cheap
how cheap you say only $20,000 and by
you I mean Anju ding yeah so so when I
was reading this in grad school it kind
of pre biased me to think like oh GPS
really cool there's a lot of computer
vision applications but it's probably
not for me yet I'm a student I don't
have this kind of cash and so I kind of
went along with with that assumption for
a good number of years but its 2018 now
so so what has happened since then there
are ways to get access to GPS now and I
sort of listed these in order of harder
to figure out down to easier to figure
out and you can argue with me afterward
whether I've got these in the right
order but these are kind of my personal
experience GPUs are computed on your
computer perhaps there's one in your
computer that you can use now I've read
that these things are more difficult to
figure out than just that and some of
the graphics cards on your computer
might not be optimized to work in that
way and so you have to do a lot of
googling I haven't bothered to do this
second you can go out and buy these
things nvidia sells them and you can buy
one and own it and keep it in your
domicile and take care of it like a pet
I don't know I don't touch hardware you
good now here we get into the space that
I am comfortable with so you can go and
rent this hardware from a cloud service
provider and you can do it pretty
cheaply
here's Amazon Web Services you can get
one for 96 hour they go up more
expensive than that obviously pretty
quickly but 90 cents an hour
very reasonable here's some from Google
Cloud all the major cloud providers have
them Asher has them I don't have a
cypher Azure
but they're all out there and they're
ready to be rented and you can go and
learn the skills to rent them very
easily but I do want to caveat this with
a couple of other thoughts like when you
or I'm assuming most our users are going
to be doing GPU compute in kind of a
hybrid way where most of your our code
is or a bunch of it will happen on CPUs
so I think CPU are and then maybe you
have a set of functions or processes
that a GPU compute might be useful for
so the hybrid approach would be lots of
VAR on CPU and then you flip over do
some GPU stuff but you're not using it
all the time for everything so you have
to sort of think about like what is your
you shits gonna be what are your needs
whatever your team's needs and sometimes
those can be very hard to predict so are
you leaving it on all the time are you
are you trying them on turning them off
you have to learn these cloud computing
skills which I'm a big proponent of I
wouldn't be and white are our talk for
me with if I didn't get up here and like
evangelize about cloud computing so you
have to get over your fear of giving
them your credit card it's okay and then
you're probably going to waste a lot of
time learning about this stuff and
you're probably gonna make mistakes and
that's okay too but learning about the
the cloud and and how to use are in the
cloud just really change my perspective
on data science and opened up a lot of
avenues for me personally so I have a
big proponent of it the last one is kind
of an interesting thing and it's fairly
new but there are now services that you
can subscribe to where you get Hardware
GPU and software as a subscription
service so here's the service offered by
map D my employer where you can
subscribe to a monthly tier system where
you are choose how much data you want to
ingest and then they
give you a rate based on that so I do
want to talk now about GPU powered
sequel engines and this is kind of the
core of what I do as a developer
advocate for map D I work with their map
D cor open source database and I try to
get people excited about using it and
trying it out so map D has has created
this sequel database that is GPU powered
and the cool thing about that is that
not only can they do things with big
data process sequel queries very fast
but you also have access to not only the
compute pipeline inside the GPU but also
the visual pipeline so you can do a
query and sequel and then very quickly
not even having to copy transition to
the graphics pipeline and create a
visual rendering which is really awesome
because the application for that is then
doing exploratory analysis odd Big Data
so I want to do a demonstration of our
open source database and a visualization
platform that is not open source but is
a great addition to sit on top of our
open source database and provide you
with some of the kind of the visual
power so showcasing the visual power of
the map D open source database so this
is 11 billion rows of data then I'm
visually like visualizing and and the
reason we could do this is the the math
T
database is doing the rendering on
server-side and it's kind of a hybrid
visualization approach where all of the
fancy visualization rendering gets taken
care of compressed down on server side
to about a hundred kilobyte static PNG
and then it gets sent client-side so
that we can interact with it very
quickly and it feels like real time
human interaction with data so we could
do things like filter very fast
take off filters zoom to new york city
and obviously you're probably thinking
like Kelly you can't show eleven billion
points on a screen like that doesn't
work so yes these are layered but but
you can zoom around and it will show you
things there's even some really fancy
stuff they do where you can show some
metadata about different points and
brush over certain periods of time
so yeah I think this is a really
powerful platform you know what what
it's lacking is kind of community
support from from data scientists from
people like the art community to come in
and try things out and and to give
feedback on what these platforms are
missing like there are a lot it is in
very early stages so so that kind of
feedback would be really useful and I
think it is really important for the art
community to become involved in projects
like GPU computing especially
open-source projects so that we can have
a say and like what happens and how data
science is affected by GPU computing and
how we can get it very quickly into our
own analyses and use it so with that I
want to say please reach out if you have
any use cases that you think would be
cool fits for this kind of solution we
have our open source projects which are
available on github and we have a
vibrant community over our at our forum
so we need our folks that would be great
to hear some of your voices in our
community and with that thank you very
much
[Applause]
you